>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Georgette Dorn: Good afternoon.
My name is Georgette Dorn and I'm
the Chief of the Hispanic Division
of the Library of Congress
and I'm very pleased
to welcome this wonderful
gathering and the Embassy of Spain.
This event is sponsored
by the Embassy of Spain
and by the Hispanic Division.
We have today with us Ana
Merino and Manuel Vilas,
two very important writers of Spain.
Ana Merino has nine books of poetry,
two theatre books, one child's novel
and numerous essays and articles.
Manuel Vilas has also a
very amazing curriculum.
He has five novels, seven books of
poetry, [inaudible] hybrid texts,
essays, in other words, so we will
hear both of them read in Spanish,
and I think there's no
need to read in English.
Right? Does everybody
know Spanish here?
Yes? No? Okay, we will then
have translations, yes.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
And there will be time
for questions afterwards.
Thank you.
Okay, so we start with Ana.
>> Ana Merino: Empiezo yo.
Para mí es un placer estar aquí,
volver otra vez a la Biblioteca del
Congreso y compartir un instante de
literatura y de amor por la
literatura y por la poesía y estar
con todos ustedes que
nos dedican tiempo,
compartir con Manuel esta lectura.
Voy a leer un poema
de mi último libro
"Los buenos propósitos"
y es el poema "Epílogo",
es el poema que cierra ese libro.
"Epílogo.
De pronto, yo era la reina
de las cuatro esquinas.
Las patas de mi cama afilaban
sus uñas contra el suelo y aquel
cemento áspero sin apenas
baldosas era como una lija.
Nadie estaba despierto velando por
mi alma y a mí no me importaba
sentir un gran vacío de insectos
venenosos anidar en mi boca.
Era la reina de las palabras
distantes pronunciadas
con meticulosidad.
Reina de las desdichas de los que
impregnan con cera sus fracasos y
habitan el enjambre de la culpa.
La miel de mi reinado era un
áspero puño seco que apretaba
mi intestino.
Yo era la reina de las cigüeñas
perezosas que se alimentaban en los
vertederos y confundían el
plástico blanquecino con
los gusanos.
Yo era esa montaña de desperdicios,
de pañales viejos indestructibles,
de chapas, de botellas,
de latas aplastadas,
de mondas cítricas
y huesos de pollo.
Mi legado de buenas intenciones,
mi reino de bondad infinita levitaba
como una nube de ácaros crecidos,
gigantescos y glotones.
La ilusión de mi imperio,
el clamor de mis súbditos,
regimiento de arácnidos, ejército
de alergias buscando la humedad
oscura en los pliegues
de las sábanas,
la destilación del sudor
primitivo convertido en banquete,
el festín de lo invisible
abriéndose camino."
Este es el poema que cierra este
libro que está lleno de buenos
propósitos, o sea, es un
libro con una voz optimista,
aunque no lo parezca
viendo este poema.
Ahora, voy a leer un poema --
un poema un poquito redentor.
Eh, una reflexión sobre la vida,
y también tiene ese tono
un poco melancólico.
"Si estás viva.
Si estás viva, tendrás que
acostumbrarte al desamor,
con su desapacible exuberancia.
Neutralizar cualquier indicio de su
patógena presencia para volverte
inmune sin perder la locura.
Ser metódica, tragar el desafecto
con ternura y reírte en secreto de
tu propia tristeza.
Si logras superar este fracaso,
te harás adicta a
lo que más te duele,
al entramado hostil de las causas
perdidas que deambulan contigo por
esa geografía de plenitud
ingrávida que te ayuda a volar
cuando los espejismos se mezclan con
las huellas de los rinocerontes que
lloran enjaulados.
Silencia lo que intuyes, drena su
desnudez para que cauterice y nunca
olvides que el tiempo enamorado
es una medicina que se agota.
Entonces no podrás
ocultar sus secuelas."
Ahora voy a leer un poema que está
traducido y Mark Aldrich va a ser
tan amable.
¿Leo primero la -- o leemos primero
la versión en inglés o -- ?
¿Leemos?
>> Mark Aldrich: ¿Primero
en inglés?
>> Ana Merino: Lo leemos primero
en inglés, si eres tan --
>> Georgette Dorn: ¿Quieres
ponerte ahí en podio?
Sí.
>> Mark Aldrich: Okay, this is a
translation by Elizabeth Polli.
"King of the House.
You grow up so you can
be King and you end
up conquering a little
piece of sidewalk.
Life stands still if the patio
where you play ceases to be so vast
and it no longer impresses you to
look at adults when they speak.
You wanted to grow up in be the
air of golden mirages like a Midas
who forgets that eating
is also necessary.
You grow up so you can be
someone carrying baggage
that has never been checked
and a wrinkled letter
that you reread every
night like a book.
Life stands still, you recognize
its face like a swing set
that calls you, and you with a man's
voice respond that it's too late,
that you can't stop being a king
begging for the love of mermaids
with tadpole skin that swim
in a sea of sewers and puddles
and fall asleep in your hands
of an insomniac tamer
of flees and lizards.
You wanted to grow up in a
circus that travels down roads
that can be dismantled where
giraffes greet the storks
from the train and the lions know
that their kingdom is
the carpet in your room.
And you grow up because you
have the power to move the toys
from their places and one day
they will stop being the skeleton
of your dreams."
>> Ana Merino: Muchísimas gracias.
>> Georgette Dorn: Muy bien.
>> Ana Merino: Muy bien leído.
Suena muy bien en inglés.
>> Manuel Vilas: Lees
muy bien, Mark.
>> Georgette Dorn: ¿Cómo?
>> Manuel Vilas: Que lee muy bien.
>> Georgette Dorn: Excelente, sí.
>> Ana Merino: Un excelente lector.
Vamos a ver si yo lo igualo.
[ Risas ]
"El rey de la casa.
Creces para ser rey y acabas
conquistando un trocito de acera.
La vida se detiene si el patio en
donde juegas deja de ser inmenso y
ya no te impresiona mirar a
los adultos cuando hablan.
Has querido crecer y ser el
heredero de espejismos dorados,
como un Midas que olvida que
comer también es necesario.
Creces para ser alguien llevando un
equipaje que nunca has facturado y
una carta arrugada que relees
como un libro por las noches.
La vida se detiene, reconoces su
rostro con forma de columpio que te
llama, y tú con voz de hombre
respondes que ya es tarde,
que no puedes dejar de ser un rey
mendigando el amor de unas sirenas
con piel de renacuajo que bucean
el mar de las alcantarillas y las
charcas y se quedan dormidas en tus
manos de domador insomne de pulgas
y lagartos.
Has querido crecer en un circo que
viaja por vías desmontables en
donde las jirafas saludan desde el
tren a las cigüeñas y los leones
saben que su reino es la alfombra de
tu cuarto y creces porque tienes el
poder de cambiar los juguetes de
sitio y un día dejarán de ser el
esqueleto de tus sueños."
Yo creo que con estos, ¿no?, ya...
>> Georgette Dorn: ¿Lo quieres
leer en inglés también?
>> Ana Merino: No, no.
Me refiero que, ¿de
tiempo qué tal vamos?
>> Georgette Dorn: No sé.
No estoy mirando la hora.
>> Manuel Vilas: Lee uno más.
>> Ana Merino: Uno más.
>> Georgette Dorn: Uno más, sí.
>> Ana Merino: Pues --
>> Georgette Dorn: Y de hecho,
Ana la grabamos el año
98 para el archivo.
>> Ana Merino: Exacto.
>> Georgette Dorn:
Cuando eras jovencita.
>> Ana Merino: Cuando era -- sí.
>> Georgette Dorn: Con tu papá.
>> Ana Merino: Era muy jovencita.
>> Georgette Dorn: Pero era niña.
Era niña.
Perdón, perdón, era una niña.
>> Ana Merino: Y yo
creo que voy a cerrar,
voy a cerrar, y es
verdad, es verdad.
Voy a cerrar --
>> Georgette Dorn: Metida de pata.
>> Ana Merino: No, no, estupendo.
Sigo, sigo con el alma.
Voy a cerrar con un poema infantil.
Espero que todos -- voy a cerrar
con un poema infantil porque quiero
reivindicar también
la poesía para niños.
Creo que la formación y la
educación para la poesía reside
desde la infancia y
también escribo para niños.
Y voy a leer un poema que es un
cuento que hace un homenaje a
una oveja.
>> Georgette Dorn: Ah.
>> Ana Merino: "La
oveja más parlanchina.
La oveja más parlanchina era
una oveja merina que abandonó su
rebaño para viajar todo el año en
un tren de mercancías que llevaba
en sus vagones lanas
de cien mil colores.
La oveja más parlanchina
fue costurera en la China,
locutora en Senegal y
maestra en el Nepal.
Era una oveja viajera con alma de
aventurera y en un cuaderno anotaba
las noches que no soñaba.
La oveja más parlanchina era una
oveja merina que buscaba en los
rincones de las viejas estaciones
el rastro de un caracol que tomaba
mucho el sol y sabía dónde estaba
el sueño que le faltaba a la
oveja charlatana.
La oveja tanto buscó que al caracol
encontró en la estación soleada de
la ciudad de las hadas y él le
dijo la verdad sobre su calamidad,
que su sueño estaba preso dentro de
un diente perverso en la boca de un
dragón que pecaba de glotón y
pocas noches dormía por la acidez
que sufría, entonces se dedicaba a
contar saltos de valla que cien mil
ovejas daban.
La oveja más parlanchina se quedó
muy sorprendida de saber que no
dormía porque un dragón
tragaldabas cien mil ovejas contaba.
Para la linda ovejita, saber que
su sueño habita en el diente de un
dragón fue peor que un coscorrón.
Se quedó desconcertada y fue a
pedirle a las hadas un consejo
luminoso que le ayudase a soñar
los sueños que le faltaban.
El diente de esa gran boca
es una celda embrujada,
le replicaron las hadas.
El dragón, cuando no duerme,
con tus sueños se entretiene.
Pero yo tengo derecho a soñar todos
mis sueños, se lamentaba la oveja.
Es injusto que el dragón
me robe lo inesperado,
el tiempo de lo soñado
que fabrica el corazón,
sollozaba con gran pena
la oveja más parlanchina,
se sentía derrotada
por una boca hechizada.
Lloraba tanto la oveja que un ratón
oyó su queja y se sintió conmovido
por el dolor tan sufrido que la
ovejita expresaba mientras con pena
contaba la historia de aquel
dragón que sus sueños le robaba.
Oveja, no llores tanto,
que yo romperé el encanto
de ese diente carcelero,
porque soy especialista en las bocas
delicadas y me han contado las hadas
que el dragón busca dentista.
Fue el roedor valeroso,
con su maletín despertó a
visitar al quejoso dragón de los
dientes viejos.
El ratón sacó palabras de un
colmillo retorcido que estaba medio
podrido y al dragón le molestaba.
Eran palabras de oveja
que el sueño deletreaba.
Eran las cosas soñadas
que la ovejita añoraba.
El ratón le dio sus sueños a la
oveja charlatana y se guardó el
diente viejo en una caja dorada.
Al dragón ya no le duelen los
dientes al masticar y la oveja
parlanchina hoy ya
puede al fin soñar."
Este es un poema con el que cierro.
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
Y que muestra un poco mi
mundo desde el lugar adulto,
que también habla con el mundo de
lo fantástico y mi mundo desde la
niñez fantástica.
>> Georgette Dorn: ¿Es
ilustrado el libro?
>> Ana Merino: Sí, por Max,
un dibujante de comics
maravilloso español.
>> Georgette Dorn: Qué bueno.
Excelente.
>> Manuel Vilas.
Lee uno más.
>> Ana Merino: ¿Qué?
>> Manuel Vilas: Lee uno más.
>> Ana Merino: No, no, Manuel.
>> Georgette Dorn: Bueno, ahora,
el próximo lector es Manuel Vilas.
>> Ana Merino: Sí.
>> Manuel Vilas: Bueno.
>> Georgette Dorn: Manuel Vilas.
>> Manuel Vilas: Buenas tardes a
todos y muchísimas gracias por
vuestra asistencia.
Voy a leer algunos poemas.
Voy a leer un poema que habla
sobre la -- es un poema viejo ya,
pero que sigue estando
de actualidad.
Es un poema del año 2003, pero que
habla sobre la condición de las
mujeres desde España
y, lógicamente,
con ánimo de ser representativo de
su condición global y universal.
"Mujeres."
Bueno, hay una cosa
que quiero explicar.
Yo utilizo mucho en mi
poesía los coloquialismos,
el lenguaje coloquial.
Pero [inaudible] no creo que sea
-- es un español, digamos, muy --
un poco de barrio,
pero es comprensible.
"¿No las ves que están
agotadas, que no se tienen en pie,
que son ellas las que
sostienen cualquier ciudad,
todas las ciudades?
Con el matrimonio,
con la maternidad,
con la viudedad, con los golpes.
Ellas cargan con este mundo,
con este sábado por la noche donde
ríen un poco frente a un vaso de
vino blanco y unas olivas.
Cargan con maridos infumables,
con novios intratables,
con padres en coma,
con hijos suspendidos.
Fuman más que los hombres.
Tienen cánceres de pulmón,
enferman, y tienen que estar guapas.
Se ponen cremas, son
una tiranía las cremas.
Perfumes y medias y bragas finas
y peinados y maquillaje y zapatos
que torturan.
Pero envejecen.
No dejan las mujeres tras de
sí nada, hijos, como mucho,
hijos que no se acuerdan
de sus madres.
Nadie se acuerda de las mujeres.
La verdad es que no
sabemos nada de ellas.
Las veo a veces en las calles,
en las tiendas, sonriendo.
Esperan a sus hijos a
la salida del colegio.
Trabajan en todas partes.
Amas de casa encerradas en
cocinas que dan a patios de luces.
Sonríen las mujeres, como
si la vida fuese buena.
En muchos países las lapidan.
En otros las violan.
En el nuestro las maltratan
hasta morir.
Trabajan fuera de casa,
y trabajan en casa,
y trabajan en las pescaderías o en
las fábricas o en las panaderías o
en los bares o en los bingos.
No sabemos en qué piensan cuando
mueren a manos de los hombres."
Voy a leer ahora otro poema que
he leído antes en la grabación,
que requiere una mínima
explicación.
Es un poema que habla
de un automóvil,
de un carro, de un coche.
Es el automóvil que
yo tenía, que --
con el cual yo había hecho muchos
viajes, y funcionaba el coche,
como decimos en España,
decimos "coche", el carro.
Iba muy bien, funcionaba muy bien.
Y falló. Y lo llevé al mecánico,
y el mecánico me dijo que
el automóvil tenía --
le fallaba una cosa -- que luego
me fascinó el nombre de la --
de las piezas del motor
del coche, del automóvil.
Que le fallaba la junta
de la culata.
Una palabra que a mí me pareció
intrigante y luego había otras
palabras intrigantes en
el motor de un automóvil.
"Cigüeñal", por
ejemplo, también me gustó.
Bueno, el caso es que la junta de la
culata era una reparación cara y no
justificada porque el coche,
el automóvil ya era viejo y no
valía la pena gastarse ese dinero
en esa reparación, y me aconsejó
que me comprara un automóvil nuevo
y que llevara el mío al desguace
y que obtuviera el plan "prever",
que era un plan que
había entonces en España,
que era que tú dabas tu
automóvil viejo y el gobierno,
si comprabas uno nuevo, te
daba una cantidad de dinero.
Te daban 400 euros.
Y, en estas, eh --
enfermó mi perro.
Mi perro enfermó también.
Entonces yo llevé -- el
perro tenía 14 años.
El coche tenía 12
años y el perro 14.
Entonces, llevé al
perro al veterinario.
Esta mañana hemos
estado hablando con Mark,
que Mark también tenía un perro.
Llevé al perro al veterinario y
el veterinario me dijo que mi perro
tenía un cáncer de hígado
y que se le podía operar,
pero que iba a sufrir muchísimo y
que iba a vivir dos mese más y que
desaconsejaba la operación y que
aconsejaba lo miso que el mecánico
del coche.
Y en ese orden de cosas, yo
pensé que el tercero era yo.
[ Risas ]
El coche -- el coche, mi perro.
El siguiente de la
cadena, de esta --
de la senectud y de la
eutanasia era yo, ¿no?
Aconsejaban la eutanasia
del automóvil,
la eutanasia del perro,
¿por qué no la mía?
Y, entonces, escribí este
poema, y este poema --
eh, dentro de este poema, hay unos
versos metidos con mala intención,
sí, con una intención
de distorsionar un poco,
del soneto más famoso de
la literatura en español,
de la literatura en
lengua castellana,
que es el soneto "Amor constante,
más allá de la muerte",
de Francisco de Quevedo.
Hay un verso de ese soneto
trasladado a este poema,
primero con una inten
-- con dos intenciones,
primero una intención de actualizar
un poco la idea que tenía Quevedo
del desgaste, y segunda, decirle
muchas veces a mis lectores,
sobre todo a los que me
leen con mala intención,
que yo también he ido a la
universidad y que he leído
perfectamente a Francisco
de Quevedo.
Y luego, en este poema, hay una
cosa que también me gusta mucho,
que en realidad fue el origen
de que yo escribiera este poema,
yo quería que mi coche, al
final de sus días, me hablara,
y como nunca me iba a
hablar él en la realidad,
pues tuve que escribir
el poema para que --
la utilidad de la literatura es
hacer que las cosas que no pueden
ser ocurran, ¿no?
En este poema, al final,
el automóvil habla.
Y como no estoy tan loco como para
darle un nombre a mi automóvil,
el poema se titula con la matrícula
que tenía, que era HU-4091-L.
"Adiós -- " Ah, una
cosa más, perdón.
A mí me gusta mucho explicar
los poemas para que la gente --
el poema está -- empieza
casi en media res,
empieza en el momento en que yo
llevo el automóvil al desguace.
Esta palabra "desguace" es el
cementerio de automóviles.
No es la misma en -- yo leí
este poema en Argentina,
y existe, no existe desguace.
Existe el desarmadero.
>> Georgette Dorn: Sí.
>> Manuel Vilas: La palabra, me
lo dijo un amigo, me dijo, no,
no es desguace aquí,
es desarmadero.
Bueno, se entiende.
"Adiós, hermano mío, la grúa
fúnebre te conduce al infierno
del desguace.
Majestuoso, vas hacia la
destrucción subido en una grúa
roja, como si fueses Luis XVI camino
de la guillotina, y yo detrás.
Pareces un rey.
Soy el único que ha
venido a tu entierro.
Te he querido.
Rezo por ti un padrenuestro
y un avemaría.
Rezo por ti y me conmuevo.
Eras el mejor.
Y lo que vivimos juntos, y
las ciudades que pisamos,
y las carreteras secundarias y
los pueblos y los mares que vimos,
y los parking subterráneos y los
túneles helados de las carreteras
de montaña, con afiladas
estalactitas a la entrada,
amenazando nuestra
milagrosa inocencia,
y los mendigos en las avenidas,
pidiendo en los semáforos en rojo,
y lo que nos amamos en la
oscuridad de las autopistas,
fundidos en un solo ser:
confundida tu carne con mi chapa.
Me salvaste de la lluvia ácida
y de la nieve sin ángeles.
Con tu aire acondicionado, que está
intacto después de doce años,
impediste que me quemara vivo
en los veranos españoles.
Ese aire frío que me
subía por la pierna.
Y eras blanco, porque la santidad
y el amor industrial y la velocidad
son blancos.
Y cómo me gustaba
tocarte las marchas,
y cómo te ponía la quinta,
y qué caña te metías,
narciso, que eras un narciso.
Y ahora todo ha acabado.
Doscientos sesenta y ocho mil
kilómetros hemos estado juntos.
Fuimos felices.
Fuimos grandes y definitivos.
Te doy un beso delante del
chatarrero y de un mendigo que lleva
un chorreante radiador en una mano.
Te he amado más que a mis amantes,
más que a mi perro; casi tanto,
pero no tanto, como al dinero.
Bueno, no te enfades, tú también
fuiste dinero, y aún lo eres,
y yo también soy dinero.
Perdona que te humille haciendo
recaer sobre tu hermosa tapicería,
sobre tus ruedas, manguitos y
válvulas que han gloriosamente
ardido, la miseria de España: el
plan Prever, 400 euros sociales.
¿Os molesta que hable de
dinero o de tan poco dinero?
Para la clase media,
que ama la limosna.
Tú, que fuiste mi libertad, que me
llevaste cerca del paraíso; tú,
que me hablabas por las
noches y me decías 'hermano,
qué bien conduces; hermano,
eres el mejor de los hombres.'"
[ Risas ]
[ Aplausos ]
Y leo el último porque el
último está traducido al inglés,
en este libro que es --
que acaba de aparecer,
que es una edición
bilingüe de español-inglés,
y este es un poema que lo he leído
antes y en realidad es un maridaje,
una boda entre Woody
Guthrie y España,
porque a mí me gusta mucho la
música americana y me gusta mucho
Bob Dylan, y el padre de
Bob Dylan es Woody Guthrie,
y Woody Guthrie tiene la
canción, que es el himno nacional,
"This Land was made for You and Me",
y a mí esa canción me parecía muy
oportuna y la idea es que presidía
esa canción y el espíritu de
Woody Guthrie para traerlos a la
convulsión, pacífica,
pero convulsión que hay ahora en
mi país, una convulsión un poco,
en fin, cansina y que,
en cualquier caso,
a mí me parece que era una buena --
un buen recordatorio hablar de Woody
Guthrie en el contexto español y lo
que a mi juicio quería
decir en su canción,
y entonces escribí este maridaje,
esta especie de traslación de
la cultura americana a un --
al contexto español, y
escribí "I love Woody Guthrie."
Y aquí, lógicamente, pues
todo lo que es España, pues,
sale toda la geografía, la
geografía española, en fin,
la península Ibérica y
en un momento en que ya --
este poema está escrito
en el 2011, por ahí,
un momento en que ya la crisis
económica en España ya es, bueno,
es obvia y es [inaudible], ¿no?
"Esta tierra fue hecha
para ti y para mí.
Desde las costas de Galicia
hasta el mar de Barcelona,
desde Cantabria hasta la ciudad de
Tarifa, esta tierra nos pertenece.
Deberíamos querernos más y caminar
por los campos con una sonrisa
inacabable en el rostro.
Desde el puerto de Somport
hasta las costas de Cádiz,
esta tierra fue hecha
para ti y para mí.
Desde la lujosa nieve del
Aneto hasta la luz de Almería,
esta tierra fue hecha
para ti y para mí.
¿Has visto el mar de Pontevedra,
has visto la belleza testaruda del
pueblo pirenaico de Gistain bajo el
sol de mayo?
Todo nos pertenece.
Esta tierra es nuestra.
Mi casa está abierta
para ti porque te quiero.
Nuestros antepasados decidieron
matarse porque eran gente sin
imaginación y no amaban
a Woody Guthrie,
pero nosotros haremos el amor
libre y repartiremos las riquezas,
porque está tierra es nuestra.
Repartiremos el oro, porque
repartir el oro es fascinante.
Si te despiden en Madrid, yo
te daré mi empleo en Sevilla.
Si te despiden en Bilbao, yo
te daré mi empleo en Valencia.
Si te despiden en Valladolid,
yo te daré mi empleo en
Santa Cruz de Tenerife.
Si nos despiden a todos, venid a
mi casa, os daré lo que tengo.
Desde las costas de Galicia
hasta el mar de Mallorca,
repartiremos todo nuestro dinero,
nuestras casas, nuestros maridos,
nuestras mujeres, nuestro plan
de pensiones, nuestros coches,
nuestros excelentes trabajos,
nuestras rentables empresas,
compartiremos todo,
porque compartirlo todo es
deslumbrante y es nuevo,
la vanguardia de lo que vendrá.
Mi casa es tuya porque te quiero,
porque quererte es
revolucionario y apasionante.
Para ti y para mí, en nuestro
honor, fue creada la tierra.
Desde las costas de Galicia
hasta el mar de Barcelona,
desde la cima de los Pirineos
hasta los vientos de Tarifa,
esta tierra fue hecha
para ti y para mí.
Desde el mar de San Sebastián
hasta el mar de Málaga,
no habrá pobreza ni alienación
ni humillación ni tristeza sino
hombres y mujeres libres, haciendo
el amor en medio del campo,
en medio de los ríos, en
medio de las tormentas,
en medio de las calles, en medio
de los campos, bajo la luna.
Y seremos felices aquí
en la tierra.
Esta tierra fue hecha
para ti y para mí."
Gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
Ahora Mark Aldrich lo va a leer
en inglés, que suena mucho mejor.
[ Risas ]
>> Mark Aldrich: Okay.
This is a translation of
Pablo Rodríguez Balbontín
with William Blair.
"I love Woody Guthrie."
Y Manuel no leyó el epígrafe que
es lo que tenía Woody Guthrie en su
guitarra, bueno, variante.
"This poem kills fascists".
>> Manuel Vilas: Sería
"This machine -- ".
>> Mark Aldrich: Right.
"This guitar kills fascists."
"This poem kills fascists.
This land was made for you and me.
From the coast of Galicia
to the sea of Barcelona.
From the Cantabrian región
to the city of Tarifa,
this land belongs to you and me.
We should love each other more
and stroll the countryside
with endless smiles on our faces.
From the Harbour of Somport
to the coast of Cádiz,
this land was made for you and me.
From the opulent snows of Mount
Aneto to the light of Almería,
this land was made for you and me.
Have you seen the Pontevedran
Sea, the stubborn beauty
of the Pyrenean villaje of
Gistain beneath the May sun?
Everything belongs to us.
This land is ours.
My home is open to you
because I love you.
Our ancestors killed each
other because they were people
without imagination and
didn't love Woody Guthrie,
but we'll make free love
and share the riches
because this land is ours.
We'll share gold because
sharing gold is fascinating.
If they fire you in Madrid,
I'll give you my job in Sevilla.
If they fire you in Bilbao, I'll
give you my job in Valencia.
If they fire you in
Valladolid, I'll give you my job
in Santa Cruz of Tenerife.
If they fire all of
us, come to my place.
I'll give you everything I have.
From the coast of Galicia to the sea
of Mallorca, we'll share our Money,
our homes, our husbands, our
wives, our pensions, our cars,
our excellent jobs, our
profitable companies.
We'll share everything, because
sharing everything is dazzling
and new, the avant-garde
of what's to come.
My home is yours because I love you,
because loving you is
revolutionary and thrilling.
For you and me, in our
honor, was created this land.
From the coast of Galicia
to the sea of Barcelona.
From the peaks of the Pyrenees
to the winds of Tarifa,
this land was made for you and me.
From the sea of San Sebastián
to the sea of Málaga,
there'll be no poverty, alienation,
humiliation nor sorrow, but free men
and women making love in the
middle of the countryside,
in the middle of rivers
and storms and streets
and the road, under the moon.
And we'll be happy here on earth.
This land was made for you and me."
>> Georgette Dorn: Very good.
[ Aplausos ]
¿Quieren leer algo más?
¿Otro más?
¿Quieres leer otro más?
>> Manuel Vilas: Si quiere Ana.
Si quiere, si alguna
persona quiere preguntar.
>> Ana Merino: Algo.
>> Manuel Vilas: Algo referido
a la literatura de Ana,
la mía o cualquier curiosidad de la
literatura española o en español o
de -- o, en fin.
>> Sí, yo sí quería preguntar.
¿Qué recomendaciones haríais a
un poeta español que quiere llegar
aquí a Estados Unidos?
¿Qué pasos tiene que hacer para
entrar en este mundo tan complicado?
De poesía --
>> Manuel Vilas: Eso
Ana lo sabe bien.
>> Y en español.
>> Manuel Vilas: Porque
ella trabaja --
>> Ana Merino: Yo dirijo el programa
de escritura creativa en español en
la Universidad de Iowa, entonces
hay muchas posibilidades de --
Estados Unidos es un país muy
generoso con los programas que tiene
de acogida para personas con
inquietudes que puedan estudiar en
Estados Unidos.
Entonces, afortunadamente,
han ido muchos españoles y también
muchos latinoamericanos a estudiar a
Estados Unidos gracias a la
infraestructura de las universidades
estadounidenses que dan ese
espacio de becas de ayudantía,
becas para estudiar
en Estados Unidos.
Una clave muy importante es
tener nivel de inglés, o sea,
estudiar mucho inglés porque casi
todas las instituciones piden un
mínimo, un C en el TOEFL
y un 26 en speaking.
Entonces, una clave es,
bueno, un buen expediente,
o sea que la universidad no es -- en
España hay que sacar buenas notas,
la gente a veces se
olvida, y estudiar inglés,
y realmente con buena cultura,
ser un buen lector, inquietudes,
curiosidad y energía,
hay muchísimas posibilidades
en Estados Unidos.
Es increíble, pero es verdad.
Yo llevo aquí 20 años y me
he hecho la carrera entera.
He seguido publicando en España.
Cuando vine a Estados Unidos, vine,
tenía bajo el brazo
el premio Adonáis,
había ganado el premio Adonáis en
el 94 y me vine a Estados Unidos en
el 95 a estudiar una maestría
por una beca de ayudantía,
y nunca volvía porque siempre este
país me ofrecía alguna cosa muy,
muy interesante, que
parecía, bueno,
una gran oportunidad, y me quedaba.
Y así, parece que fue ayer,
pero han pasado 20 años.
>> Georgette Dorn: Casi, casi 20.
>> Ana Merino: Y he tenido la suerte
de tener lectores en América Latina
y en España y continúa,
y en Estados Unidos también
tengo muchos lectores.
Aquí hay 45 millones
de hispanoparlantes.
Es un mundo apasionante.
Es parte de nuestra identidad.
Compartimos el idioma, la pasión
y también hay una cosa que le
comentaba a Mark, Estados Unidos es
un país generoso de hispanistas.
Hay muchísimos anglosajones
que aman la cultura en español,
y la defienden y la promueven y
la estudian y la conocen mejor que
nosotros mismos, y
gracias a ese amor,
y aquí lo vemos en la
Biblioteca del Congreso, bueno,
pues tenemos esta solidez
como cultura multicultural,
llena de grandes diversidades
y de una gran pasión.
Entonces, pues, lo
que diría es que sí,
hay muchas oportunidades
en este país.
>> Georgette Dorn: Pero ustedes
dos están con la Agencia Cultural
Española en Dickinson,
¿no es verdad?
>> Ana Merino: Sí.
>> Georgette Dorn:
Tanto Juan como Ana --
>> Ana Merino: Manuel.
Sí.
>> Manuel Vilas: Claro,
por el Dickinson y --
>> Ana Merino: Y Acción Cultural.
>> Manuel Vilas: Entre las dos --
>> Ana Merino: Que en este
caso, nos ha invitado.
>> Georgette Dorn: ¿Por un
año entero o medio año?
>> Ana Merino: No, no, tres semanas.
>> Manuel Vilas: Tres semanas.
>> Ana Merino: Tres semanas
haciendo talleres y charlas.
>> Manuel Vilas: Dickinson College
y con el patrocinio de Acción
Cultural Española y también
de la Universidad de Dickinson.
>> Georgette Dorn:
Que es una gran idea.
Una gran idea, eso.
>> Ana Merino: Claro.
Sí, que vengan escritores,
claro, en períodos pequeños,
tengan oportunidad de estar
en la zona, eso es estupendo.
Pero yo creo que la pregunta
iba más dirigida para jóvenes,
para jóvenes que quieren
iniciar la aventura americana.
Y, bueno, y en ese sentido, las
universidades estadounidenses,
desde los departamentos
de estudios hispánicos,
dan muchas oportunidades.
Eso sí, tienes que [inaudible],
depende del estado que te toque,
clima adverso -- o sea,
uno tiene que crecer, ¿no?
Y adaptarse a otro idioma,
muchas veces, etcétera.
>> Georgette Dorn: Y el gran giro
en España es integrar a España con
América Latina.
>> Ana Merino: Claro, por supuesto.
Eso ya es parte --
>> Georgette Dorn: Eso ya
desde el siglo XIX, casi.
[Inaudible]
>> Ana Merino: Claro,
y Federico de Oníz,
cuando va -- él, cuando va a --
>> Georgette Dorn: A Harvard.
>> Ana Merino: No,
él fue a Columbia.
>> Georgette Dorn: A
Columbia, sí, sí.
>> Ana Merino: Y trabaja en el
centro de Columbia y monta el
departamento y se divide en --
>> Georgette Dorn: Y traduce
libros, empieza a traducir libros.
>> Ana Merino: Claro.
Y también fue el que
apoyó a Gabriela Mistral.
>> Georgette Dorn:
Claro, exactamente.
>> Ana Merino: Gabriela
Mistral, "Desolación",
no se hubiera publi -- o sea,
se publica gracias a Oníz,
que reúne a los maestros
hispanistas.
Dice, hay una poeta muy interesante,
que está publicando en revistas,
pero no se la conoce porque no tiene
libro, entonces los maestros --
porque Federico Oníz estaba
formando maestros de español.
>> Gerogette Dorn: En los años 20.
>> Ana Merino: Claro,
porque después de la
Primera Guerra Mundial,
cambia el eje de interés
lingüístico.
Antes, el eje era el alemán.
Por eso, en esta franja
de Estados Unidos,
hay tantos departamentos muy
sólidos históricamente de alemán
y francés, cambia el eje a partir
de la Primera Guerra Mundial,
y cambia el eje y empieza
un interés,
a revolotear un interés por
el español y también por las
relaciones que se están
estableciendo de Estados Unidos con
América Latina y el
área de influencia.
Es muy, muy interesante.
Es una de las historias
más apasionantes,
que no nos damos cuenta de lo
apasionante que ha sido el español
en Estados Unidos en el siglo XX,
que se tendría que estudiar
a fondo porque hay, bueno,
una interrelación y, cuando digo
el español como la idea que tenía
Oníz, que era toda, era
toda la -- tola la con --
todo el conjunto de
hispanoparlantes.
Y ahora es mucho más apasionante
porque hay una identidad en español
en Estados Unidos, desde
el mundo latino que, bueno,
que es vibrante y que
es otro país más.
>> Georgette Dorn: Jacinto Benavente
estuvo en Yale en los años 20.
Así que --
>> Ana Merino: Exacto.
O sea, ha habido, sí,
hay una gran tradición.
>> Georgette Dorn: Y
Francisco Aguilera,
que fundó el Archivo de
la Palabra, en el '43,
estuvo también en
Yale en los años 20.
Conocía a Oníz y vino aquí
a la Unión Panamericana,
en los '30 y a la Biblioteca
en el año 42.
Así que él fundó el Archivo
de la Palabra, que ya --
hemos grabado a Gabriela Mistral.
>> Ana Merino: Claro.
Pues, una maravilla.
>> Georgette Dorn: Que
hay ninguna grabación.
Es la única grabación
literaria que existe de Mistral,
la que hizo en el año 52.
>> Ana Merino: Ahá.
>> Georgette Dorn: Sí.
>> Manuel Vilas: Aquí,
la hizo aquí.
>> Georgette Dorn: Sí.
En ese mismo lugar donde
tú grabaste esta mañana,
ahí mismo grabó ella.
>> Ana Merino: Ahá.
Qué maravilla.
>> Georgette Dorn: Que ya era
bastante anciana y no estaba bien.
>> Ana Merino: Claro.
Exacto.
>> Manuel Vilas: He
notado la presencia.
[ Risas ]
>> Ana Merino: No, no,
pero es fascinante.
Es fascinante, porque muchas veces,
tendemos a pensar en Estados
Unidos como solo un espacio,
como espacio anglosajón, y mucha de
la -- del enriquecimiento cultural,
del intercambio, de la reflexión se
ha hecho también de nuestra cultura
en español, porque digo en
español que nos une a todos.
Tendría que hacer Manuel un
poema que hablase desde Canadá a
la Patagonia.
Desde, ¿no?, porque
-- hasta Filipinas.
O sea, hay una -- ha habido un --
pues eso, un intercambio y
un movimiento de escritores,
de intelectuales, de pensadores y
también la ayuda magnífica del
hispanismo que ha tenido
esa curiosidad, incluso,
que ha apoyado muchas veces esos
hispanistas anglosajones que se han
apasionado por lo que ofrece nuestra
profunda cultura en todos sus
países, y queremos que esto
siga vivo y qué hay que hacer.
>> Manuel Vilas: Ahí
hay un tema de fondo,
que es un tema del que
se habla ya bastante,
que es finalmente la transformación
del español en lengua de cultura en
Estados Unidos, que eso es lo
que -- el debate final es ese.
Es decir, el español es una lengua
con un potencial demográfico
impresionante en Estados
Unidos, pero hace falta que se --
que eso dé paso al español
como lengua de cultura.
Es decir, que el interés por el
español no sea solo que lo habla
mucha gente, sino que haya
detrás construcciones culturales,
literatura, arte, pensamiento,
ciencia, tecnología,
empresas importantes que se
construyen del español también,
y ahí es donde hay, a mi
juicio, bastante dejación,
sobre todo por -- en fin, pienso
que se podría hacer más cosas.
>> Por ejemplo, ¿conocéis alguna
editorial aquí en los Estados
Unidos que publica exclusivamente
en español literatura para los
jóvenes que crean [inaudible]?
>> Ana Merino: Claro,
hay editoriales.
Hay editoriales, tanto las grandes,
porque Santillana está en Miami,
o sea, hay editoriales fuertes en
español que están abriendo un
mercado aquí, que se está
preocupando por no quedarse solo en
el bestseller, porque
muchas veces, cuando uno --
yo hablo con muchas comunidades
hispanas viviendo en Estados Unidos,
me dicen que cuando
vamos a buscar libros,
se nos hace muy difícil,
y es verdad.
Luego, hay editoriales que apuestan,
como la editorial que ha
publicado la poesía de Manuel,
que son editoriales
independientes, son bridged press,
que apuestan por el español, que
apuestan -- [inaudible] ¿Qué?
[Inaudible] Exacto.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> Ana Merino: Luego está Literal
en Houston, luego está, eh --
Sí, hay en Miami, hay, hay
editoriales, La Pereza, chiquititas,
que se animan, que tienen
mucho estímulo, entonces eso,
indudablemente, le da mucha riqueza,
porque además como este es un país
construido por emprendedores que
creen en algo y apuestan por
ello y se entregan, ¿no?
El editor de Manuel
es un apasionado.
De pronto, ves que empiezan a
moverlo y eso anima muchísimo y,
muchas veces, es el germen de
realmente transformaciones.
Volvemos a ver el ejemplo de
"Desolación" de Gabriela Mistral.
Es un grupo de hispanistas que se
juntan y sacan el primer libro de la
que luego será nuestro
Premio Nobel,
mujer Premio Nobel en español.
O sea, es un germen de
casualidades, de apasionamientos,
de interés, de curiosidad.
>> ¿Y qué relación
tenéis con los traductores?
¿Tú traduces tus poemas?
>> Ana Merino: No.
Tengo, siempre he tenido
buena relación,
en el sentido que he tenido la
suerte de mi traductora al inglés o
al alemán, pues, de conocerlas,
intercambiar, Manuel igual,
con sus traductores también,
de francés [inaudible].
>> Manuel Vilas: Sí, [inaudible].
Este libro lo tradujeron un español
y un americano y luego, a mí --
era un poco de taller, [inaudible],
porque se hizo mientras yo
estaba en Iowa, y nos reuníamos.
Me preguntaban [inaudible], sobre
todo era la parte coloquial,
cómo trasladar, eh -- sí,
había que buscar los coloquialismos
equivalentes en inglés, que no --
la traducción literal es
absurda, no, no tiene sentido.
Hay que conocer los equivalentes.
No es cuestión, por ejemplo,
en español coloquial de Madrid,
por ejemplo, digo "qué
fuerte", "qué fuerte".
No vas a decir -- tienes que buscar
el equivalente en los contextos
lingüísticos en donde un
americano diría esa expresión y
ver qué expresión es.
Pues todo eso es un
-- es apasionante.
Los talleres de traducción, en
ese sentido, son apasionantes,
porque se ve, bueno, pues
hay que investigar, ¿no?
No es una traducción literal.
De hecho, una traducción,
lo peor que le pueden hacer
a un escritor es que le
traduzcan literalmente.
>> Georgette Dorn: Es lo peor, sí.
>> Manuel Vilas: Es lo peor.
>> Georgette Dorn:
Es fatal [inaudible]
>> Manuel Vilas: Lo peor.
>> Georgette Dorn: Y además que,
lo que hacen es traducir
cada palabra --
>> Manuel Vilas: Claro.
>> Georgette Dorn: Como darle
vuelta a un abrigo, ¿no?
Y sale ridículo, sí.
>> Manuel Vilas: Sí, yo [inaudible]
como lector de traducciones
[inaudible] en castellano,
pues a veces ves cosas que
dices, pues, madre mía.
O sea, yo recuerdo hay unas
traducciones de Shakespeare en
español que son literales,
y claro dices, bueno,
si esto es Shakespeare, en
fin, hay que traducir --
es importante en ese sentido, sobre
todo en la poesía, que quien --
que haya una sensibilidad muy
literaria por parte de quien --
de la lengua de llegada, de quien
maneja la lengua de llegada.
El otro día, no sé dónde era,
ponía el caso a una clase de
Dickinson, ponía el caso, eh,
en español, las mejores
traducciones que hay del ruso
Dostoyevski están hechos por un
escritor que se llama Cansinos
Assens, que tradujo a
Dostoyevski del francés [risa].
>> Georgette Dorn: Esa
es una tragedia, ¿no?
Porque eso es como --
>> Manuel Vilas: No, pero
son las mejores traducciones.
Porque Cansinos era un escritor,
era un escritor español,
tomó las traducciones de
Dostoyevski del francés,
pero ahora han traducido,
muchos tradujeron directamente a
Dostoyevski del ruso y son peores
traducciones porque no dominan
la lengua literaria que Cansinos
sí dominaba.
Entonces, claro, tú dices, bueno,
a lo mejor Cansinos
aquí ha sido infiel,
pero yo prefiero la infidelidad
de Cansinos a que me traduzcan una
barbaridad que en español no
suene a nada, y que me digan, no,
esto es una [inaudible], pero es
que he sido fiel a Dostoyevski.
Pero esto, que esto no es español.
Entonces, ahí está el
dilema de las traducciones.
>> Georgette Dorn: Pero
recién lo traducen creo que --
bueno, "La guerra y la paz",
que reciñen la traducen del
ruso al español en la Argentina,
porque también, lo mismo pasó
con, este, con "La guerra y la paz".
>> Manuel Vilas: Claro,
pero es que en España,
en los años 20, nadie sabía ruso.
Entonces, había curiosidad.
>> Ana Merino: Aparte que, claro --
>> Manuel Vilas: Había curiosidad
por leer a Dostoyevski y dijo
Cansinos, no hay problema,
coge -- él sabía francés,
cogió las traducciones francesas de
Dostoyevski y las pasó al español,
y ha quedado una cosa estupenda.
[ Risas ]
>> Georgette Dorn: Pero traducir
poesía es aún más difícil,
porque tiene que ser un --
>> Manuel Vilas: Hay
que ser un poeta.
Hay, por ejemplo, hay un [inaudible]
>> Georgette Dorn: Hay que
ser poeta y hay que ser un --
>> Manuel Vilas: Es que, en
realidad, en la traducción,
las traducciones más modélicas de
poesía en español es la que hizo
Jorge Guillén de "El cementerio
marino" de Paul Valéry.
Pero, ¿qué hizo él?
Más que una traducción es la
construcción de un poema, eh,
es decir, gemelo del de
Paul Valéry, en español.
En realidad, él construyó
un gemelo en español.
Entonces, claro, tú puedes leer
el poema de Jorge Guillén en sí
mismo, independ -- es decir,
estás leyendo a Paul Valéry y
estás leyendo a Jorge Guillén en
un fundido.
Ahora, eso es la excelencia.
Para eso, tienes que contar con un
poeta como Jorge Guillén que le dé
por traducir a Paul Valéry.
De modo que -- todo -- está --
detrás de la traducción están
todos estos problemas, ¿verdad?
>> Georgette Dorn: En el caso tuyo,
tenías un poeta y
un traductor, ¿no?
>> Manuel Vilas: Sí.
No, no, eran -- los
dos eran traductores,
pero con mucha sensibilidad hacia
la poesía y con una gran --
el caso de Pablo [inaudible] es
una persona licenciada en letras,
con estudios --
>> Ana Merino: Y ambos con
mucho sentido del humor,
porque hay que entender
el humor de Manuel, ¿no?
Y entenderlo y americanizarlo.
[inaudible] está muy bien hecha.
>> Manuel Vilas: Había una cosa
con relación al traductor que es
triste, que está ocurriendo,
que es debido a la
mercantilización del libro,
la figura del traductor
se ha oscurecido.
Digamos, mucha gente se compra
una novela de donde sea,
estás en España, te compras una
novela del [inaudible] Philip Roth y
creyendo que estás leyendo a Philip
Roth y estás leyendo a un traductor
de Philip Roth.
Entonces, esta consciencia
de la tradu --
de la importancia del
traductor hay que reivindicarla,
porque ¿tú estás leyendo, estás
leyendo la prosa de Philip Roth?
No. Estás leyendo la prosa de
un traductor de Philip Roth.
>> Ana Merino: Pero que está --
hay algo muy interesante,
¿no?, que es --
>> Georgette Dorn: Hay que
conocer el contexto histórico,
social completamente.
>> Ana Merino: Claro.
>> Manuel Vilas: Claro.
Ahora ha salido un
libro, precisamente,
ahora hay un poco de
debate sobre este tema.
>> Georgette Dorn:
Una pregunta aquí.
>> ¿[Inaudible] contrario a
traducir poesía [inaudible]?
>> Ana Merino: Yo estoy
trabajando a James Galvin.
Me gustaría sacar -- que
es un poeta americano,
me gustaría sacar algo, y voy
lenta como el caballo de los malos,
porque entre que te enfrentas
al poema, voy acumulando,
voy creando la carpeta y me
surgen mil cosas de trabajo,
porque además para la
traducción necesitas verdaderamente
concentración, oído, ritmo.
O sea, si vas a hacer ese --
>> Georgette Dorn: Es
muy difícil traducir.
>> Ana Merino: Es difícil.
>> Georgette Dorn:
Y poesía aún más.
>> Ana Merino: Yo veo a veces a
personas que conozco que con una
alegría sacan unas
traducciones que digo, bueno,
¿seré yo que todavía soy tímida?
Llevo 20 años en Estados Unidos
enfrentándome al inglés y tengo
una ti -- pero, bueno, a veces,
pienso en colegas en España que,
bueno, que a lo mejor
desde esa ingenuidad, pues,
se enfrentan al idioma
de otra manera.
Pero, me parece muy interesante a
mí la traducción y ver cómo me
traducen o ver cómo
se hacen traducciones.
Me gusta mucho las
ediciones bilingües,
porque te ofrecen esa doble
mirada, ese análisis,
ese enfrentamiento de
dos idiomas, esa --
y luego ver cómo generan un ritmo
distinto y cómo generan imágenes.
Eso me parece muy interesante,
y en poesía es una
muy buena oportunidad.
>> Manuel Vilas: Yo tradujo
por lo general del francés,
pero por gusto personal, y además
con ánimo de infidelidad total a la
-- por ver cómo sería
la lengua, o sea,
cómo sonaría en español
algo, pero claro, tienes,
hay que ser muy infiel a la --
es decir, la traducción literal,
a mí me parece que
es un error total.
>> Georgette Dorn: Terrible, sí.
Bueno, el español está
cambiando también aquí mucho,
y hay una academia
norteamericana de la lengua.
>> Ana Merino: Claro.
>> Georgette Dorn: Y están
desesperadamente tratando de
mantener que en español sea
coherente gramáticamente correcto,
porque hay tanta traducción
terrible.
>> Manuel Vilas: Eso es importante.
O sea --
>> Georgette Dorn: Y
también, digamos --
>> Manuel Vilas: No,
pero el mantenimiento de la
norma culta en cualquier lengua,
eso es fundamental.
En inglés, en alemán, en español.
O sea, tiene que haber un
mantenimiento de la norma culta.
>> Ana Merino: Si no, se fragmenta.
>> Manuel Vilas: Porque si no --
>> Ana Merino: [Inaudible]
en otros idiomas.
>> Georgette Dorn: En eso estamos.
>> Manuel Vilas: Si no aparece
el peligro de la fragmentación,
que es lo peor que le puede pasar
a una lengua, que se fragmente.
>> Georgette Dorn: Por ejemplo,
usan palabras como "parquear".
>> Manuel Vilas: Pero
eso, eso, la, las --
>> Georgette Dorn: Voy
a comprar groserías.
Voy a parquear el carro
para comprar grocerías.
>> Manuel Vilas: Pero eso no es --
[ Risas ]
>> Georgette Dorn: No, es verdad.
Es en Arizona.
>> Manuel Vilas: Sí, pero
eso -- eh, pero el problema,
yo soy filólogo, el
problema es el vocabu --
bueno, aquí hay filólogos,
hay filólogos también.
>> Ana Merino: Sí, un montón.
>> Georgette Dorn: Sí, es verdad.
>> Manuel Vilas: El léxico, los
problemas no están en el léxico.
El problema de la fragmentación
es en la sintaxis, o sea,
cuando empieza a cambiarse
los órdenes gramaticales,
entonces sí que hay -- Y que se
introduzca la palabra "parquear",
bueno, cualquiera sabe
perfectamente.
A un español de la
península Ibérica, pues,
enseguida sabe parkings, sabe --
en España se llaman
parkings, cuando vas --
>> Georgette Dorn: Ah,
[inaudible] ¿se usa parking?
Entonces, parking, aparquear --
>> Ana Merino: Claro, pero ese
es un debate muy interesante.
Mi padre es académico.
>> Georgette Dorn: Sí, ya
sé, lo conozco a tu papá.
>> Ana Merino: Y, por eso, y están
siempre con la pelea, diciendo,
pero, ¿cómo es posible
que ahora, de pronto,
el español esté impregnado
en la ciudad de frases y frases
en inglés?
O sea, tú vas por las calles de
Madrid y ves la tienda "outlet".
¿Cómo que "oulet"?
"CEO", ¿Cómo que "CEO"?
O sea, de pronto,
estás absolutamente rodeado de
palabras en inglés porque en
España se ha puesto de moda.
Entonces --
>> Manuel Vilas: Pero
detrás de eso --
>> Ana Merino: Hay un debate
muy interesante sobre cómo la
publicidad --
>> Manuel Vilas: Detrás de eso hay
un problema cultural de gran calado.
Yo tengo un hermano que tiene
una tienda de ropa y que no --
y que le puso un nombre en
inglés a la tienda de ropa.
Pero está pasando, pero
está pasando, claro,
pero ocurre constantemente en
España, hasta tal punto que --
>> Georgette Dorn: Pero
inglés correcto, ¿no?
>> Manuel Vilas: Sí.
Ya, pero, porque si tú abres
un negocio y le das un nombre en
inglés, ese negocio
parece más convincente,
y parece que vayas a comprar
en él algo de más calidad.
Hay -- eso, detrás, deja ver una
cosa muy grave que está ocurriendo
en España, que es la desconfianza
hacia los productos nacionales.
>> Georgette Dorn: Eso
pasa acá también.
Eso pasa acá.
>> Manuel Vilas: Entonces tú
pones "rebajas" o "outlet".
[inaudible audience comment] Bien.
[ Risas ]
>> Manuel Vilas: Pero es un
fenómeno sociológico que hay
detrás muy triste, que es la
desconfianza del español hacia sus
propios productos.
Entonces pues dice, esto es
"outlet", esto vendrá de América,
esto -- seguro que aquí es mejor
que no en uno que ponga "rebajas".
Y así con todo, en
los restaurantes, pues,
con el genitivo sajón, todos --
se llaman Alfredo, "Alfredo's".
[ Risas ]
Así constantemente.
Pero hay detrás de eso --
no es simplemente una boda,
hay una desconfianza de -- hacia
los produ -- y eso sí que es grave.
A mí me parece grave, porque --
>> Georgette Dorn: Eso
pasa acá también.
Lo francés es más elegante
que lo americano, ¿no?
En el Japón, los japoneses locos
por todo lo extranjero, ¿no?
Sí, María.
>> Gracias.
Me ha encantado vuestra
lectura y vuestros poemas.
Luego, quizás podamos comp --
Saben cómo comprarlos, ¿no?
>> Ana Merino: Ah, sí, hay
unos -- sí, hemos traído.
>> Ah, bueno.
>> Georgette Dorn: Ya es hora.
>> [Inaudible] por la poesía.
¿Qué momento vive la
poesía en español?
¿Y qué os parece [inaudible]?
No, pero en la literatura
en español, ¿no?
Y luego, en términos
de que el lector es --
[inaudible] Hay mucho interés,
hay muy buenos lectores.
¿Cómo -- ?
>> Ana Merino: Yo creo que
es un momento muy bueno,
un momento bueno en el sentido en
el que, bueno, hay muchos poetas,
muchas editoriales, mucha
calidad y, bueno, que hay que --
hay que mantenerlo, hay que --
y que venimos de una tradición
muy grande de la poesía.
No sabemos cómo en
mundo digital, cómo --
otros espacios van a interactuar
y cómo construir lectores.
Yo creo que el -- por eso, yo
reivindico mucho la educación,
la lectura desde la
infancia de poesía.
A mí me parece fundamental,
y el apoyo al profesorado,
profesorado básico hay que
apoyarle para entender --
para que entiendan la literatura,
se sienta apoyado y la
poesía esté presente.
Ahí hay una labor que tenemos
que hacer desde la educación.
>> Manuel Vilas: Bueno, España es
un país que tiene una tradición,
o sea, de tener algo realmente,
tiene una tradición poética
importante desde siempre.
Es decir, es un país con poetas.
Es un país de poetas.
Probablemente, probablemente la
-- si somos incluso objetivos,
es más relevante, puede que sea
más relevante la poesía en España
que la novela en estos
momentos, ¿no?
Y, porque ha habido siempre
una tradición constante.
Claro, hay un momento elevadísimo
en la poesía en español en el
siglo XX en España, que es
la generación del 27, claro,
que aparecen ahí seis o
siete poetas de una calidad
extraordinaria, y por otro
lado están los mayores del 27,
Machado, Juan Ramón.
Entonces, hay, se juntan ahí
una serie de grandes poetas que,
prácticamente, ocupan
todo el siglo.
Pero luego, en el siglo,
a mitad del siglo,
aparecen otros poetas importantes.
Por ejemplo, la figura de Jaime
Gil de Biedma sigue siendo un
poeta nuclear.
Probablemente, sigue siendo el poeta
más leído y más relevante de la
segunda mitad del siglo XX.
Y ahora, en España, en
términos editoriales,
es un país que tiene un montón de
editoriales de poesía y es un país
donde hay festivales de po --
cualquier ciudad tiene
un festival de poesía.
Se lo estaba comentando, te lo
comentaba antes, que, bueno, Madrid,
Barcelona, Sevilla, todos
tienen, en todas las ciudades,
en Córdoba hay una [inaudible] De
modo que hay un interés constante
por la poesía.
Y la juventud, la gente joven está
mirando al género como con --
le ven muchísimas
posibilidades de expresión.
Hay también una parte muy
interesante que es nueva,
que es la parte, que yo la
estoy viendo sobre todo.
En España, ahora, hay muchas
ciudades donde la gente se socializa
con la poesía.
Van a los bares y hay lecturas
de poesía, y entonces, hombre,
a lo mejor eso no sé lo que
saldrá, pero salen ahí,
todo el mundo va con sus
poemas, salen ahí a leer, bueno,
quizás muchos para
ligar también, ¿no?
[risas]
Entonces, leen los poemas y tal y
gentes de veintitantos años que le
han visto posibilidades al género,
pues, para hablar con los demás,
para socializarse, etcétera.
Y eso es nuevo, eso
también está --
Y hay otro fenómeno nuevo
en España que es reciente,
que tiene cuatro días, que es
la aparición de bestsellers
de poesía.
Entonces, es una cosa.
Claro, los poetas serios se han
cabreado mucho, están enfadados,
¿adónde van estos, que no
saben nada y venden cuarenta mil,
cincuenta mil ejemplares?
Entonces, han aparecido poetas que
escriben para adolescentes y, pues,
están vendiendo muchísimo
más que novelas.
O sea, una cosa -- Entonces, tú
ahora entras en una librería y,
normalmente, pues la poesía
siempre estaba arrinconada y tal,
y ahora te la encuentras
en la primera --
a primera vista, te encuentras
ahí, ¿no?, estos poetas,
que son doce o catorce y
que venden muchos libros.
Hay los turcos [inaudible].
>> Ana Merino: Sí, Marwan.
>> A Marwan, que había venido,
que se autoeditó un libro y vendió
veinte mil ejemplares de un libro
autoeditado, autoeditado.
[Inaudible] lo contrató Planeta.
>> Ana Merino: Es un
tipo de poesía --
>> Manuel Vilas: Marwan.
>> Ana Merino: Es un tipo de poesía
muy musical, muy adolescente.
Lo ideal es que desde ese espacio
adolescente de leer poesía de amor,
de sentimientos, tengas curiosidad
y quieras seguir leyendo poesía.
O sea que, en ese sentido, yo lo veo
cuando hay gente que se lleva las
manos a la cabeza y digo,
mira, hay espacio para todo.
Lo importante es que el lector no
se conforme y diga, "bueno, sí,
cuando era adolescente me encantaba
leer esto, voy a seguir leyendo,
ver otras posibilidades,
voy a ampliar la mirada".
Entonces, yo creo que toda
literatura funciona en determinados
espacios y puede ser un estímulo,
igual que cuando eres niño,
leer poesía infantil, etcétera,
que tienes diferentes momentos en
los que vas descubriendo el idioma y
las posibilidades.
Pero está generando un
debate muy interesante.
>> Manuel Vilas: Yo creo que
es una cosa interesantísima.
Ya te digo, porque de repente ha
visibilizado el género y, a ver,
[inaudible], no vas a
esperar grandes poetas allí,
pero de entrada, un librero,
que un librero estaba acostumbrado
a meter los libros de poesía en el
último estante, de repente,
los tiene que poner en el primer
escaparate de la librería porque se
los están pidiendo.
Entonces, los está vendiendo.
Ya te digo, este poeta,
[inaudible] un tipo estupendo,
ha vendido un montón,
lo ha contratado Planeta.
O sea, esto, rápidamente uno cuando
se encuentra que de repente un
sello, que da igual, si haces
un manual de cocina y vendes
ochocientos mil ejemplares, te
contrata una editorial grande.
Es decir que no -- el
género poético, de repente,
vende cuarenta mil,
cincuenta mil libros, pues,
han ido los grandes
editores, claro, por --
entonces, muchos editores están
editando este tipo de poesía.
Y yo no creo que sea malo --
>> Georgette Dorn: Bueno,
muchas gracias a todos ustedes.
Quieren vender libros,
seguro, ¿sí?
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.